Jordan Harbinger is here from the Jordan
Harbinger show yeah
publish a French one of the biggest
podcasts of 2018 yeah ain't it yeah Wow
who made the list of like the top 50
podcasts of the year last year which is
amazing because Jordan was on another
big podcast called the art of charm
uh-huh
it was a terrible breakup Jordans left
there on his own on an island trying to
figure out what am I gonna do now and
all of a sudden he comes to the end of
2018 and the Jordan Harbinger show where
it's just him this is one of the top 50
podcasts in the world isn't that right
who are you doing the art of charm with
I was doing that show with two dudes
that were are you familiar with the term
deadweight yeah that's what he calls his
penis yeah really good yeah yeah it was
funny cuz I remember going oh my god how
am I gonna do this show with like my
core team had left with me and I thought
thank God for that but you know I have
all these resources that I don't or had
all these resources that I won't have
anymore
and now what I realize now is oh wait
having people tell you that everything
you do sucks and that you'll never you
know you can't do this you can't do it
that's not a resource actually parents
yeah it's like parents that go what are
you gonna get a job and you're like I
have a morning show every single day
that airs across North America yeah but
are you gonna go to medical school it's
like okay all right at some point you
got to leave it who are these guys how
did you know them we met when I was in
grad school and when I used to be a
lawyer
which is like not something I usually
talk about in publisher Bundy both yeah
that's great company and so when I met
the that's this one guy we started the
show when I was still in law school and
then when I moved here to New York in
2003 or something like that after loss
or no sorry 2007 we were teaching guys
basically like picking up girls all the
time it started off as a dating thing
and I never liked funny velvet hat oh my
god no we were like mystery yeah mystery
cool yeah these
like counterpoint I got a know he's got
goggles tell me more necessary yes hi
hello Pig oh yeah I want to know you
nobody talks to me like that
exacto dating yeah it was dating thing
and we were kind of trying to be the
counterpoint to that exact right just
getting yeah cuz it was like we realized
as functional humans that like the women
that would respond to that we're
probably not the kind of women you
wanted to it probably the type of women
that would fall for a guy like B yeah
abducted in planes they probably want
the type of thing you'd like to [ __ ]
though nice just dumb models oh yeah
want to be negative that if they weren't
that great at conversations yeah
abducted in plain sight is on my list
sorry no I didn't mean to okay it's it's
hot as in it has a lot of plays on
Netflix oh no I mean I jerk off you just
let's go back to overtime there's that
so we I hire some of these guys that I
was doing the old show with because I
was a lawyer and I was like I can't hang
out with dudes all day and all night so
four o'clock in the morning I gotta get
up at like 8:00 and go into an office
and not be hungover everyday all the
kind of law real estate finance very
exciting yeah you ever heard of
mortgage-backed securities that's ignite
tenderize speak it hard yeah
so that's what we were doing that's what
I was doing and then I would come home
and there'd be like this apartment it
was all out of my apartment back then
and now it now it's funny we've come
full circle now there's a studio in my
house so how long were you doing it and
how long before you knew like oh these
guys I got the [ __ ] these guys I did
this I did the old show for 11 years so
I've been doing a podcast for 12 years
okay zhis and I knew though and then I
literally realized those guys we're not
gonna work out right like 20/20
hindsight within the first probably four
or five years which actually is a really
long time that is a while yeah yeah but
still I mean then you got the five or
six years on the back end and networks
just held and you know and people being
like people being like hey what are you
gonna split off in your own Mike
I can't you know we came up see uh we
run this business together but it made
the decision really easy when I had no
choice I guess
no when it wasn't a decision when they
gave you the boot fire exactly yeah
essentially we were negotiating an
amicable split they can't really fire me
I still own a third of the company to
this day to this day you get paid no I'm
well yeah eventually that's it maybe
that's what we're trying to have any
money I see yeah hence my law degrees
come in full circle - now that I think
about it yeah weird I didn't see the art
of charm on the top-50 podcast of the
year they're not they are it's funny how
yeah it's funny when you fire all the
talent on the show things go downhill
did you hear that 20 days manager yep
yeah that serious can't get rid of a top
talent so did you you change the show
because the show isn't Jordan Harbinger
show is not just a show about picking up
chicks no there's no dating on it pretty
much at all right which I thought people
went oh man you're screwed you changed
everything
you're gonna lose half your audience
what I found was like the bottom crusty
10% that you wouldn't scrape off the
bottom of your shoe is like I don't like
the new show and I'm like oh good
because you're the one on Twitter who's
like I need more about how to pick up
girls at funerals and I'm like can you
take that I'd like to know
yes score some sweet puss yeah [ __ ]
one crying over the casket how do you
pull that off some wedding crashers type
stuff little car exactly so but the rest
of the audience was like finally so it
was almost like I was the last one I was
like the last guy to that party where I
realized and this is sort of a greater
thing like I was the last person to
realize hey I probably could have moved
on earlier because my audience was like
finally can we can we not talk about
this dumb crap anymore because what was
really popular was the stuff I was doing
that I considered to be off-topic where
I'd have somebody come in and talk about
like how they escaped North Korea or
something like that so you just like
doing interesting conversations or do
you look at it as like a wellness sort
of improve your life type of podcast
it's a little bit of both no wellness
because I don't I don't do like health
because I need to be able to call BS on
stuff that is actual BS and I can't do
that if I'm like oh okay mitochondria
like last I heard of that was
by oh and ninth grade I can't really be
like yeah but if someone comes on and
it's like if you just think about it
enough it'll happen I'm like wait a
minute
yeah that I know is a bunch of baloney
yeah so don't bring that in here tell me
something practical that the audience
can use to actually get better and if
they're like well then it's a it's a
massive you don't buy the secret no I
hate that stuff yeah whether they just
think positive thoughts and now things
will happen but the universe don't
without the universe there was one
chapter in the secret when I realized
think this really is real where they
literally said you should cover up the
numbers on your scale don't use a scale
and don't even worry about dieting think
thin thoughts they said that's what
really makes sense yeah yeah you think
thin thoughts now you'd be amazed at how
the weight just disappear there's still
the same thing it's dieting cuz you
won't eat as much that's nothing about
that it's notice that that's what got
you right yeah yeah yeah just yeah I
thought aids so you are you as weight by
the way I did yeah you look better thank
you
yeah not that you look bad I did I was a
fat and I looked horrible I was yeah
[ __ ] Natalie from the facts of life
so let me ask you to Ju I think we might
have talked about last time where you've
been in North Korea yeah
how many times four times and even after
that otto was his name Otto warm warm
beer you didn't weren't alarm do not
want to go back I did not go back after
that oh you have nothing but no I have
not because one of the things you like
to do over there was take flash like
that what's funny it what's funny / not
funny is I do have a bunch of propaganda
posters oh my god Frank how'd you get
them I bought them but like you don't
know that you don't get a receipt where
you're on the plane and they're like sir
did you steal that and you're like not
hold on I got that at the got that at
the store that sells propaganda posters
it's like people give them to you that
when you ask for them or you trade for
them or you buy them but of course he
took his off the wall which was not
advisable I've read it's real bad for
that guy cuz of course people go oh what
an idiot he went there I'm like okay no
matter what he's like 20 and died if I
get imagine the dumbest thing you did at
age 20 yeah having a death sentence and
none of us would be here yeah comedy age
I every night yeah would you go back if
you now the relations are a little bit
better I don't see them just randomly
kid
rapping Americans especially with the
others some kind of a potential for a
relationship that was my favorite part
of State of the Union last night when
Trump gave himself the pat on the back
and he was like you know if I wasn't the
president we'd be at war with North
Korea right now
well we technically I mean I mean we
still are yeah yeah Wow you said no
they're gonna B's going back at the end
of the month to talk to his friend Kim
Jong again is that happening that's
that's I mean that's a miracle yeah yep
he's going back and it pains me to say
it pains me to say but he got it done he
did I mean yeah at least open the door
it's not done yet
I think I'm conversation done the fact
that a conversation even happened that
is a miracle right I cannot be like well
you know I don't like him so here's a
reason why I'm gonna [ __ ] on that he is
and that is amazing nobody has done that
for frickin 60 years where do they meet
they were Singapore Vietnam Oh Vietnam
this time they're gonna meet in Vietnam
yeah Wow yeah announced that last night
there's news Kim could come here I guess
he doesn't want to he would be allowed
to leave man I think you got to find the
middle ground where it's not like you
know it's so important to them and I'm
not going all the way to you but you're
not going all the way to me so it's like
nobody's giving up that sort of an alpha
thing but wouldn't it be like if like if
you're a welcome guest in the United
States you'd be the first I don't know
yeah maybe maybe America is not quite
ready to make him that sort of welcome
guess maybe I don't know okay maybe he
would come a fuse invite yeah there's a
hole I used to work actually for the
State Department in an embassy and I
found that like the whole diplomatic
thing it's a whole thing there's a whole
protocol thing that we that I still
don't understand where because I'm like
just fly them over here who cares right
don't put them to Disneyland everything
will be fine you can't there's a whole
rigmarole like step by step by step
thing where you don't just be like you
know what we've been fighting for a
while won't you come on over to the
White House it's like whoa it's too much
right it's like meeting the family on
the first date it's like look I like you
and everything but do I need to meet
your grandma
not really right there's there's a set
of traditions we how long ago that's
interesting job I did that for not that
long actually that was that was about
like a year oh yeah
which embassy you don't say Panama
Panama yes oh my god I've had that on
repeat for
like year-and-a-half so at what point
did you start podcasting full-time like
this is the gig so
don't know if you remember that
recession in 2008 were something about
mortgage-backed securities and what we
were doing causing that whole problem
they they basically said look sure to
listen to Christian Bale in that glass
his eye no they said look we're gonna
get more work for you guys around May
and at this point it's like September of
the previous year I went well this isn't
really gonna further my career and
they're like it's not you're gonna you
should look for another job
but until you find another job we'll pay
you and I said for how long because this
is great like I get to show up every day
and get paid but they're like yeah but
your career is being stifled now is just
thinking well you know your career is
being stifled my career my career is not
this so whatever and so they they got
really lucky that basically paid me for
like nine and a half months full salary
and benefits and a wall street gig I
didn't get any bonuses or anything right
but like you know what and we weren't
even showing up after a while they were
like you don't have to come in there's
nothing but but having an office in
world financial number two away with a
computer and a phone that they said you
could use and then just being able to
shut the door actually I got a lot of
work done so I started my business my
old business which I guess now is
partially my new business I started it
with full essentially my salary and my
office and funding everything and they
were like yeah if you need to print
something print something you need to
use the phone use the phone and so I
would bring him I would bring in
recording equipment set up in a
conference room do interviews and
instead of being like come to my dirty
apartment with 16 dudes sleeping on
couches in like Broad Street yeah I go
hey come to world financial number two
go to security get a tag like you do
here yeah come on up to conference room
62 be and I'll be in there and people
would walk in and be like wow how 6 just
how successful is this podcast was cool
with it
they were fine with it that's great
they're like what are you doing and I
was like oh I'm doing some interviews
and stuff they were like hey look
whatever we just feel bad that we're
basically like torpedoing your career
yeah yeah as a second year lawyer after
you studied for three years took the bar
exam in New York passed and then we're
like hey oh wait we blew up the whole
economy so yeah realistic owned a place
in New York I didn't I was rented
because I was 27 I mean now you know no
you don't might be that'd be big the
best is you know you know every trick
these [ __ ] real estate agents are
holding all the [ __ ]
and finding the deals yeah there was a
lot of that although real estate finance
mostly it's like you're looking at
commercial buildings like the like this
one that we're in and they're like yeah
they're getting 15th mortgage loan
backwards as thing about finance and so
we just need to make sure that all of
the pieces of the building that it says
are on this plan are in the building so
I would literally look at something and
they'd be like are there 467 parking
spaces in this development in
southeastern Florida and I'd be like see
you guys in three hours
one two I mean you do a lot of stuff
like that
being a people think being a lawyer is
like you're hammering away in court or
you're doing some interesting stuff your
first few years you are like that if
they gave that task to the secretary
she'd be like Shh I'm not doing that
Yeah right but you do it or they'll give
you an eight hundred page document and
I'll go can you proofread this and I'll
go what am I looking for and like you
know like mistakes and I go yeah there's
40 missing commas there's a couple of
citations that aren't there there's a
couple pages that are just blank in the
middle and they're like great thanks
because they have to pay your on salary
so there's looking for things to give
you that you're qualified to do and I'm
good enough to do the big [ __ ] yet not
even close no I there was there are
numerous occasions as a Wall Street
attorney where I we be negotiating with
like some Turkish coca-cola executives
and they would be so slow and
inefficient and indecisive that my the
partner who's controlling it would go
hey they're saying that they have a
flight out in four hours and that they
have to go and pack we're gonna send you
to their hotel and you pack their stuff
from the hotel and bring it here so we
buy an extra like two and a half hours
of time to negotiate and I would go in
to this hotel and like pack this dude's
smelly and dirty stuff into a suitcase
and bring it back and then they would be
like thanks for doing that
clearly demeaning tasks he didn't pass
the bar exam in New York to do this but
you know what it's it's like that's what
you do as a first in session or
associate there's no glamour involved in
that one more amazed that the Turkish
guys let you touch their stuff I know I
would know but he packed myself can you
imagine thinking about now so Barris you
travel with that yes they do good you
have to you have to use it every day
what dick health is important I know I
drink out of it oh I see I see I see
like a thermos you gotta plug the bottom
[Laughter]
you made a ton of great guests on your
podcast oh yeah
I was looking at one I was watching one
last night you had that guy Darren Brown
that guy is amazing that okay plus
interviews ever okay so I'm trying to
I'm trying to figure out so he's a
Mentalist this guy Darren Brown he's
British but he's starting to gain some
traction in the states because he's
putting out these Netflix specials and
people are getting into it but the one
that I watched
did you see it the push oh that's one of
my favorite things okay so he did this
special of the push and it's like on an
hour and all it is is you start and it's
hidden cameras everywhere and you set up
a scenario where the person doesn't know
they're being filmed everywhere the
person doesn't know but the idea is that
by the end of the night you have to take
a person from average start all good
whatever to working on their brains so
much that you can convince them to
murder somebody to the point where they
actually think they've murdered somebody
by the end of the night like the end of
this special is there's a guy sitting on
a Ledge oh and you've been working on
this guy so much that he's convinced he
has to push the guy off the ledge and
there's a bungee attached to him and
everything but there's you know five
seconds where the guy goes holy [ __ ] I
just killed somebody yeah well does he
know there's a bungee attached or no no
no no nobody knows nobody's ever seen
this and it's crazy what's amazing is
you watch the whole special and there's
spoiler but you watch the whole special
and at the end of it the guys like no
I'm not gonna push this guy off and your
faith in humanity is restored and then
Darren Brown comes in there's only like
two minutes left in the special but he
goes oh but just so you know he's not
the only one we did this with and you
see a montage it was like five other
people yeah and they all push the guy
off he's like the only one that didn't
do yeah let me show you him right and
you're like holy [ __ ] but then I was
like and I don't know any of Darren
Browns other stuff right but I'm going
is this guy a Mentalist or is he just a
bully who is just beating down your
brain so badly like like it like you
would do to a torture victim that you
can convince them to do anything see the
one that did that cool the invisibility
thing where they teach to the
convinced a regular person that they are
in I have seen that's a different guy
that's a magic for humans or something
like that was weird where they're like
oh that's why we watched it that guy's
really interesting too and that was
that's really funny where the whole
audience is in on it but it's similar in
that the whole audience or everyone else
is in on it there's another Darrin brown
one that's not on Netflix and he this
this good-for-nothing like loaf kid who
just drinks and like doesn't appreciate
his parents here he convinces probably
an intern here he he gets he convinces
his kid that basically he woke up and
like a zombie apocalypse and like
everyone's dead and he's got to turn
this kid into a hero and like there's
hundreds of people in on this in
real-time and they're messing with his
phone that because they like the hack
his phone so it doesn't work cuz of
course he's just like in a closed-off
area probably like you know Idaho see
none of the Darren brown stuff is done
with that sort of wink that the Justin
Willman stuff Justin Willman stuff it's
all done kind of fun yeah like the
Darryl Brown stuff is not fun I'm
looking at this going okay like that's
really interesting to watch but I'm
pretty sure that everybody involved is
gonna have PTSD after this for sure yeah
it has to screen people I asked him
about this on the show he has to screen
people because there's the the other one
on Netflix is called a sacrifice and he
can there's this guy who's like I'm not
racist I just think white people are
better right he's one of those like a
Liam Neeson tight yeah he convinces this
guy to jump in front of a bullet for a
guy he thinks is an illegal immigrant
from Mexico when these bikers are about
to shoot him uh-huh and the guy is like
you know freaking out and and he's
wearing a vest that explodes and this
fake blood goes everywhere and he thinks
he's been shot but like and it's good to
not be racist but at the same time
you're watching somebody's whole idea of
who they are get completely shattered
like they leave this thing every morning
maybe he leaves this thing not racist
anymore I guess kinda but also having no
clue who he is like what the [ __ ] I've
just been completely reconstructed as a
person and I'm an adult human being how
long the specials they're like an hour
I'll watch he's not a comic right no
Aaron broke a leg do you see the one
where they had the kid was Clapton's kid
no but but did you I mean how does he
how do you what do you think of that cuz
I kind of see him and I'm like oh I I
don't know if you're tricking people as
much as you're torturing people I think
it's genius because look the people who
are convinced to kill someone they
should be weeded out I should know what
they are now they're gonna go wait a
minute I every time I'm asked to do
these little things that lead up to
something bigger yeah they're gonna have
more defenses built up against that
everybody who watches that that's true
now when I'm like hey can you uh hold
this coffee now throw it in Sam's face
you know you're like wait Michelle of
the person they used to be going like I
can't believe okay more killing somebody
I can't believe I did this
Nate on TV doing it what am i doing yeah
now a bad person forever exactly didn't
know they were a bad person until
[ __ ] Darren showed up and it's like
by the way I fixed you but your whole
life before this you were a shitty human
being so I did ask him about this and
and the truth is he's like look after
this they go and see a psychologist for
a little bit because it they're not bad
pieces and especially it's like you're
not a bad person for having done this we
literally manipulated you into baby
steps and then he kind of walks him
through it and he's like look you're not
a bad person because and think the first
sort of compliance step is they've got
these trays of hors d'oeuvres and yeah
it's like can you help put these
vegetarian flags and the vegetarian ones
in the and the regular ones not and then
he's like oh crap we don't have any
vegetarian ones just put the vegetarian
legs in the ones with me these people
will never know it's fine and hit
they're like oh um all right I guess
right because it's kind of harmless and
then it's like oh well this other thing
happened you have to pretend to be the
donor cuz he didn't show up so once
they've misbehaved a little bit they
misbehave a little more you know they're
being filmed no they don't know they
know it's all hidden camera how do they
get them to it's it's basically they
auditioned for something like months ago
and signed the waiver okay and then
there's
for like a catering job they signed a
waiver
like three months prior for a TV show
yeah and then they were like sorry you
didn't get the show and they're like
whatever and then three months later
like hey um you need temp work is it
we have a catering thing for this
charity event you're gonna be the
assistant to the organizer so it's like
put the little flag the vegetarian flags
in and then after that it's like oh
shoot the donor you know he had a heart
attack you gotta help me move his body
before all the people come in but it's
like these little tiny gradients and
then it's it comes into the whole murder
thing
are they miked or no the whole area
seems to be Mike yeah it's like room oh
yes it's not lapels okay that's good
yeah it's not fake I'm not saying it is
I don't have to ask you that I don't
want to go in skeptical like a lot of
times audio gives away of something is
faked or the audio is too clear good
point I hadn't thought of but were the
camera angles like if there's a camera
angle that's supposed to be stationary
but you see it move a little bit or it's
too perfect or its frame to right or the
audio is too clear that that always
gives away the things are staged I was
watching a certain hidden-camera show
that I'm not going to mention which one
yeah on an airplane next to Jim and the
whole time I'm like like enjoying it and
Jim's just looking over at the seat and
he's like hey how'd they get that angle
hmm and I went oh you [ __ ] yeah I think
I think about that sometimes you're
obviously better at it than me but some
tile be like oh my god and my wife will
go that can't be real and I'll be like
it's totally real it's totally real and
then I'll google it and someone's like
you know that time when they're like
directly there's no way that somebody
got a full facial genre they're not
moving out of the shot at all and
they're saying like this could be the
last time we ever see each other and
it's like fade to black and it's like
how did you get that
no wait everyone was in on this and I'm
the only idiot that didn't get yeah the
movie ending believe in you who do you
have coming up you know that's wise
actually there's so many there's so many
good ones
I have Russell Brand coming up hopefully
I don't go Russell Brand's Twitter
videos great talker like explaining this
[ __ ] so how about this okay so Russell
Brand is one of these guys that kind of
speaks on the dangers of social media
through social media yeah I saw you
literally just did a podcast about the
leading social media yes promoted mainly
on social media like I know the irony
there is not lost on me how it like a
digital age as it's called like how do
you realistically go yeah I'm a
podcaster who kind of thinks that social
medias bad well podcasting I don't think
is social media but I do think that
Instagram and Twitter are def obviously
social media and the problem that I've
I've had is I didn't have Instagram
until October of 2017
I just resisted it I was like I'm not
doing this and then I sort of didn't
mess with it for a while I just uploaded
an occasional photos and then like
midway through 2018 I started to look at
it and use it a lot and I started to
just feel like my life sucked oh yeah
you know and I was like oh man you know
I'm starting my show over with the
Jordan Harbinger show and I got all this
other stuff gone and look at all these
people and I was never the guy who
looked at Facebook and went there on
vacation in the sunny plays my life
sucks I never cared but somehow
Instagram was able to fine-tune itself
to do like do just punch me in the
shoulder a couple times a day
and so it just became this welt that I
didn't forget about and so I stopped
looking at other people's stuff and if
somebody was really posting a lot of
FOMO like fear of missing out using BS I
literally blocked them you can't just
unfollow because they'll show up and
like your frickin Explorer window so I
had to block people even friends of mine
and they're like hey did you see my post
I'm like no offence I actually blocked
you because all of the stuff that you're
doing is interesting and I don't want to
get sucked into it and they're like well
that's a weird thing to do right but I'm
like look you're a marketer you're good
at it
I don't want to be subjected to it and
so but why not just enjoy your life and
just enjoy you know look a there's you
doesn't have to hide away from yours I
totally agree with that but but I could
theoretically found that psychologically
I can which is weird because if
someone's on Twitter they're like Jordan
years you suck I'm like an whatever
right but if I look at somebody else's
Instagram in their in their doing
something that I think I'm so it's not
like I wish my life was like that I just
go oh shoot I should also be doing I
should go to the gym and do this or oh
I'm not power lifting I'm just working
out shoot I should be doing so it's not
they're not
trying to make me feel bad I'm doing it
to myself and I realized I couldn't turn
it off just take away the take away the
temptation to feel that way yeah and try
don't post workout Vince because I don't
want to make people feel better
absolutely yeah yeah people in Dachau
will be jealous one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM f
[Music]